[Musique]
par toute une série d'innovations le
président de la république monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing a voulu
redonner cette année au 14 juillet un
caractère de grande fête populaire et le
conserver son aspect easton
c'est pour cette raison que ce défilé a
été transporté des champs-elysées à la
bastille lieu le plus symbolique de la
révolution française et vers des
quartiers plus habités afin que le
maximum de parisiens puissent en
profiter
c'est par un décret de 1880 que la fête
nationale a été fixée en france au 14
juillet il faut remonter à 1945 pour
voir la fête nationale
exceptionnellement marquée par un grand
défilé militaire entre la bastille et la
république sur le même itinéraire que
celui choisi par le président de
république 1974 que pensent les
parisiens de ce nouveau défilé
ça c'est une bastille qui n'est pas la
même parce que la véritable bastille et
ben c'était celle que j'avais dans mon
coeur elle est transformée en western se
joue très contente parce que toujours
oui moi je suis pas du tout d'accord qui
m 14 juillet ici à la bastille c'est
tout ça me dérange quand beaucoup de mon
temps j'ai l'impression qu'ici ils
auront beaucoup moins de place aux
champs-elysées sont venise et s'en est
désistée pour les étrangers clermont ask
com dérangé alors comme je vois la
télévision votent et médicales
dans l'ensemble c'est une idée comme une
autre enfin les blancs des abus mais
toutes les rues de paris avec je tique
c'est une économie restrictions de
carburant
1 le carburant il ya y vas y en a les
avions qui volaient recul est pas autant
qu'un temps quand un avion alors faut
être gentil faire des économies mieux
les faire là dessus sur le chauffage
les maisons l'hiver ou même pour les
véhicules
oui évidemment je vois pas très bien moi
où tu pourrais des blindés dans huit
mois à mon avis va y avoir certainement
des embouteillages monstres la cérémonie
commencera à 9h 15 lorsque le président
la république accompagné du premier
ministre du ministre de la défense
nationale arrivera sur le quai de
montebello afin de passer les pop corn
9h25 monsieur giscard d'estaing déposera
une gerbe au pied de la colonne de
juillet avant de prendre place sur la
tribune officielle composée uniquement
de trouver à pied ce défilé rassemblera
treize mille hommes qui marcheront
derrière 38 drapeau ou et tendent à
quand les fils aériens
il commencera à 9h30 à noter enfin qu
arrivée place de la république les
troupes regagneront leur véhicule par la
rue de turbigo le boulevard saint-martin
et magenta
pour la première fois depuis de
nombreuses années les pompiers de paris
ne défileront pas à bord de leurs engins
d'un centre créé par napoléon 1er en
1811 le corps des sapeurs pompiers de
paris et depuis le 1er mars 1967
érigé en brigade cette prestigieuse
unité forme encore appartient à l'arme
du génie et son commandement est assuré
par le général fait rouge qui vient
d'être promu au rang de commandeur dans
l'ordre de la légion d'honneur
cette brigade a pour principale mission
d'assurer en toutes circonstances la
protection la sécurité des personnes
contre la serbie ainsi que les périls
des accidents de toute nature les 133
communes y compris paris où s'exerce sa
compétence regroupe une population
supérieure à 6 millions cinq cent mille
habitants
articulée en 60 18 centre de secours
cette unité dispose de six milles 320
gradés et sapeurs et 2010 pour l'année
1973 le bilan opérationnel de la brigade
fut de 80 mille cinq cents interventions
dont plus de 5000 asphyxie et plus de
12000 incendie 2 102 sapeurs pompiers
furent blessés au cours de
l'intervention
[Musique]
cette année encore vous pourrez
applaudir les détachements du personnel
féminin désormais de terre de mer et de
l'air en ce qui concerne les pépins
attaché case assure principalement des
fonctions de convoyeuse de l'air à bord
d'avions de transport militaire le
personnel navigant occupant des postes
de rédactrice interprète opératrice en
transmission ou encore secrétaire
dactylo ce qui bien sûr n'a rien à voir
avec les nippes au tce
[Musique]
parmi les hommes élites nous retiendrons
cette année la présence du 1er régiment
de chasseurs parachutistes de stationner
ap le 1er rcp qui n'appartient l'armée
de terre que depuis 1945 a pris part ou
campagne d'italie de france et
d'indochine son drapeau porte la croix
de guerre 39 45 avec deux palmes et
celle des théâtres d'opérations
extérieures avec cette panne
derrière le 1er rcp vous pourrez admirer
le 8e régiment de parachutistes
d'infanterie de marine qui avec ses 24
années d'existence et ses 14 années de
campagne et le régiment des
parachutistes engagés français
[Musique]
voici maintenant le 13e bataillon de
chasseurs alpins coiffé de la célèbre
retard créé en 1853 besançon le 13e bca
participa aux opérations de kabylie et
du maroc puis de la guerre de 1870 où il
s'illustra à froeschwiller est basé
engagés dans la première guerre mondiale
il se distingua sur tous les fronts de
la belgique à la champagne de la somme à
l'italie en passant par la picardie le
chemin des dames les vosges et l'alsace
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale il
est envoyé en norvège et dans la somme
dissous en 1942 il se disperse dans les
maquis de savoie plus combat dans les
alpes où il s'illustre notamment au
combat du col du petit saint bernard à
partir de 1945 s'ils séjournent dans le
tyrol autrichien
en 1952 il revient à chambéry où il
forme juste en 1962 des combattants pour
l'afrique du nord
aujourd'hui le 13e bca et fier d'être
titulaire de neuf citations à l'ordre de
l'armée et la croix de guerre norvégien
oui c'est bien la légion étrangère qui
clôturera ce défilé du 14 juillet 1974
dans l'articulation suivante emblème et
chef de corps du 1er régiment étranger
la musique de la légion une section de
pionnier un escadron du 1er régiment
étranger de cavalerie une compagnie du
2e régiment étranger une compagnie du 2e
régiment étranger de parachutistes au
son du boudin la musique de la région
qui se compose de santé exécutant
défilera comme à l'habitude à la cadence
de 90 pas mieux avec leurs barbes leur
tablier depuis orange et leur âge sur
l'épaule et pionnier perpétueront le
respect des traditions et la ford région
aidera ensuite le premier en garnison à
orange il participa aux campagnes du
maroc et de syrie vise la campagne de
france au débarquement en provence à la
libération des projets de l'alsace et
aux opérations d'indochine et de
l'algérie compte étendard du 1er rec est
décoré de 2 quad pierre et sipa le 2e
rei est l'héritier d'un passé lourd de
gloire acquise au long de 127 années
d'existence formé en 1841 il parcourt
quatre continents et inscrit 18 bataille
sur les 60 rapeau proclamé libérateur
d'italie il est second dans l'ordre des
combats accompli dans les régimes et
ronge le deuxième rêve hérité du 2e
bataillon étranger de parachutistes
largués sur le camp retranché de dien
bien phu
puis participe aux opérations de
maintien de l'ordre en algérie en
garnison à calvi il appartient à la 2e
brigade aéroportée dans les rangs de
laquelle il est intervenu au tchad
[Musique]
devant de tels faits d'armes
une chose reste certaine on ne parlera
jamais assez de la légion étrangère et
des hommes qui la sert
[Musique]